bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle édition du 78 lactu
de ce jeudi 20 mars jour du printemps et
comme tous les jours vous le savez nous
allons faire le point sur votre
actualité locale tout d'abord C
information sur le dossier de
l'Université de Versailles 50 ans en
Yveline l'établissement semble être
sauvé du moins à court terme l'État a
annoncé qu'il verserait une une avance
remboursable de 2,6 million d'euros en
décembre dernier déjà le ministère de
l'enseignement supérieur avait dû verser
800000 € je vous le rappelle cette
annonce est tombé en même temps que le
rapport de la Cour des comptes qui
couvre la période 2006 2012 et reprend
des critiques déjà émises lors de la
découverte du déficit du budget de
l'UVSQ notamment on peut y voir des
opérations de partenariat public privé
mal géré un recours excessif aux heures
supplémentaires ou encore une
augmentation mal maîtrisée des emplois
dossier à suivre évidemment lancé par la
Ligue féminine de basket en 2005
l'opération marine de cœur permet de
faire découvrir le sport aux jeunes
filles des quartiers populaires
notamment cette année les joueuses
professionneles de calis faisaient
office d'entraîneur un petit peu à
Mantel jolie Patrick Jacques de dixmud
pour les images on va apprendre la
manipulation de balle le drible est-ce
que vous avez déjà fait du basket oui à
l'école ou en club va t'inscrire au club
ou le contrôle du ballon est encore
parfois hésitant et pour cause la
plupart de ces jeunes filles jouent pour
la première fois au basket c'était bien
on a appris comment fallait jouer au
basket et si comme ça au moins la
prochaine fois si on refait du basket à
l'école ou autre bah on serura quoi
faire sur des ateliers de passe de tir
ou de drible ces jeunes ivelinoises
manient le ballon sur les conseils des
joueuses professionnel de Calais
actuellement en tête du championnat de
2uxè ligue féminine elles sont venues
partager leur passion entre deux jours
d'entraînement c'est sûr que ça change
de d'habitude après c'est vrai que c'est
toujours sympa d'apprendre ce qui est
nous notre métier à des jeunes mais
pourquoi pas des futures basketteuses on
essaie surtout qu'elles s'amuse c'est
une journée où elle s'amuse et si ell
s'amuse c'est qu'elles vont aimer donc
pour nous c'est tout gagné initié il y a
9 ans par la Ligue féminine de basket
l'opération marine de cœur est un projet
unique en France qui n'existe dans
aucune autre discipline l'objectif dans
les Yvelines faire découvrir le basket à
des jeunes filles issues de quartiers
sensibles qui n'ont pas l'habitude de
côtoyer les parquets et les terrains de
sport c'est un leur faire découvrir le
sport de les mettre en relation par
atelier avec effectivement des des
exercices qui permettent de comprendre
ce qu'est le basket il y a aussi dans ce
cadre là un atelier de discussion avec
une joueuse de haut niveau pour leur
montrer un petit peu qu'est-ce que c'est
que le sport de haut niveau comment on
peut y parvenir le département des
ivelines est le premier de France en
terme d'évolution de licencié féminine
avec 12% d'augmentation 2013 et
peut-être que parmi les 180 jeunes
filles présentes ce mercredi certaines
fouleront les parquets du département
dans les prochains
mois vous le savez le 20 mars ouvre la
saison du printemps également c'est la
journée mondiale du bonheur et pour être
heureux vous allez désormais pouvoir
vous aider de ce livre petite
philosophie pour grandir dont l'auteur
est à mes côté Charlen guinoiso bonsoir
à vous merci d'être là tout d'abord
évidemment dans cette journée inter
national du bonheur j'ai envie de vous
demander par rapport à ce livre quelle
est votre conception du bonheur et bien
pour moi le bonheur ce serait d'être soi
et de d'être prêt à accueillir la joie
quand elle se présente comme aujourd'hui
ce grand soleil vous êtes éditrice de
métier je le rappelle c'est votre
premier ouvrage en tant que auteur
comment est venue cette idée justement
de cette envie d'écrire ce premier livre
et bien j'écris depuis que je suis toute
petite dans mes carnets des poèmes plein
de choses et donc j'ai toujours eu envie
de d'évoluer dans l'univers du livre et
de l'écrit donc je me suis dirigée vers
l'édition de manière assez naturelle et
puis en fait ce livre je le porte en moi
depuis très longtemps depuis des années
j'ai beaucoup réfléchi à l'enfance au
fait de grandir quand est-ce qu'on est
adulte est-ce que c'est une question
d'âge est-ce qu'on peut grandir
plusieurs fois dans une vie et donc
voilà dans le cadre de d'une collection
que nous lancionss dirigée par Catherine
Rambert ce thème m'est apparu grandir
puisque je devais en choisir plusieurs
et je me suis dit que je ne pouvais pas
le ne pas l'écrire moi-même c'était un
peu une urgence pour moi vous l'avez
écrit d'ailleurs en très peu de temps en
2 mois le temps d'un été quasiment à
travers petite philosophie pour grandir
quelle message vous voulez adresser à
vos futurs lecteurs ah le message
premier c'est c'est vraiment d'être soi
et de ne pas avoir peur de d'accepter
ces blessures ces failles ces faiblesses
qui n'en sont peut-être pas d'ailleurs
et de vraiment de d'avancer de et de
faire de son histoire sa meilleure allié
par rapport à ce livre il y a plein
d'évidences en fin de compte
h é au on pas Leen c'est un peu ça il
parfois quand une chose est juste devant
nous on la voit pas et en fait
effectivement beaucoup d'évidences qu'il
est bon parfois de de se rappeler et
d'en faire quelque chose à soi en fait
je le rappelle ce livre est sorti il y a
quelques semaines dans les librairies
est-ce que justement cet ouvrage vous a
fait grandir un petit peu d'une certaine
manière oui oui et bien oui puisquen
l'écrivant forcément j'ai dû retourner
en arrière dans ma dans ma propre
histoire et puis avancer plus loin et et
puis tout ce que ça m'apporte
aujourd'hui tous les tous les messages
que je reçois et cetera me faut encore
grandir et àre AC vous ce soir me fait
grandir aussi pour préparer ce journal
évidemment je l'ai je l'ai dévoré si
j'ose dire puisqu'il est vraiment très
intéressant alors je vais je vais en
prendre une ou deux de phrases que que
j'ai trouvé intéressantes on va les
commenter si vous voulez bien pourquoi
sans vouloir de pleurer chaque larme
verser dessine une marre de sel à nos
pieds gment les cortenasses dans nos
souliers voilà de pieds tout neufs pour
quel est le message le message et bien
c'est que quand on a vécu quelque chose
de difficile peu importe l'échelle de
cette chose c'est bien de pouvoir
l'exprimer et on se lave quelque part et
et voilà après on est on est prêt à
avancer et à accueillir le bonheur quand
il se présente et puis il y a une des
dernières phrases qui nous intéresse un
petit peu plus les journalistes qui est
assez assez drôle le savoir et la photo
d'un instant T une photo jaunie au
regard du lendemain chic de beau
reportages reste à venir j'avais pas
pensé à celle-ci bien oui puisqueen fait
arrivé à la fin de ce livre je me suis
dit que si je l'écrivais dans 2 mois
dans 6 mois ou dans 10 ans il serait
différent et j'ai trouvé chouette de se
dire que justement c'était le dernier
message à apporter qu'on pouvait grandir
encore beaucoup que ce qu'on écrit
aujourd'hui n'est pas le reflet de ce
qu'on écrira demain et que donc tant
mieux il y a encore plein de choses à
découvrir alors vos phrases préférées
dedans quelles sont-elles il y en a une
ou deux j'imagine qui vous tienent
particulièrement à cœur non oui alors
ben je tombe spontanément dessus ça
tombe bien l'une de mes Pr préféré il y
en a deux en fait ce sont la première
les plus grands explorateurs parcourent
les terres de leurs peine puisque je
pense que se découvrir soi-même passe
par par découvrir sa propre histoire la
redécouvrir et et en faire quelque chose
de fort pour soi et la deuxième alors je
vais essayer de vous la trouver
rapidement mais
elle est je la connais par cœur je la
connais par cœur c'est le fait de se
dire que parfois il faut se dire de
monter sur un tabouret lever les bras en
l'air et se dire que rien n'est
impossible quand on a un rêve il faut il
faut se l'offrir voilà céit une sorte de
rêve justement ce livbre pour vous non
oui oui bien sûr bien sûr que vous
concrétisez du coup depuis quelques
semaines dans dans vos cuusqu vous
faites alors il y a des il y a des
phrases assez intéressantes sur les
cauchemars ça s'adresse j'imagine un
petit peu plus aux enfants mais quand on
écrit quand on écrit justement un livre
comme ça on se dit que l'auteur fait
peut-être encore quelques cauchemars non
mais on en fait tous mais c'était oui
c'était en fait c'était imagé c'est soit
quand on fait des cauchemars la nuit ou
des rêves qui nous paraissent bizarres
c'est intéressant de s'y conf onter de
se demander ce qu'il nous rappelle et ce
qu'il signifie pour nous ils peuvent
vraiment nous faire avancer et puis à
travers les monstres le fait de ne pas
avoir peur des monstre quand on est
petit c'est quelque part nos plus
grandes angoisses nos plus grandes peurs
ne pas avoir peur de les découvrir d'une
façon ou d'une autre pour avancer on
parle de de de belles phrases d'évidence
et aussi de cauchemar peut-être un peu
plus pour les enfants il s'adresse à
tout le monde quand même ce livre c'est
ouvert à tousad oui çaadresse à partir
de l'adolescence des adolescents jusqu'à
97 ans
j'espère justement vous parlez de des
personnes de 97 ans ces personnes âgées
vous parlez à plusieurs reprises dans ce
livre on voit quelques phrases sur la
sagesse à quel moment vous pensez qu'on
est qu'on est sage et qu'on est grand
alors je pense qu'on peut à la fin je
pense que quand on vieillit on a
forcément vécu beaucoup de choses
rencontrer beaucoup de personnes on a
été confronté à plein de belles choses
et on a plus de recul donc quand on a
plus de recul à priori on approche de la
sagesse même s'il faut pas faire de
généralité et si vous aussi vous voulez
grandir comme Charlen Guinoiseau vous
pourrez donc vous offrir ce ce livre
petite philosophie pour grandir à 12,95
€ dans toutes les librairies on pourra
vous rencontrer si on le souhaite aussi
pour parler un petit peu plus de tous
ces enseignements lors d'une dédicace au
salon du livre ce samedi matin et vous
serez dans les ivelines ça c'est
important au centre commercial véisi 2
le 12 avril pardon prochain merci
beaucoup charoiseau d'être passé sur le
78 lactu toute autre chose municipale
vous le savez dans quelques jours c'est
le premier tour de cette élection locale
Henry paayux à coanière Claude buyet à
boisarc ou encore guimalandin à trappe
trois mères sortant senior qui brigent
un nouveau mandat dans ses municipal
2014 Olivier Maniscalco vous dresse le
portrait de ces candidats doyens dont
les Yvelines et les années surtout
n'altèrent pas du tout le dévouement
pour leur commune Henry paayux et Claude
vuyet ne sont pas du même bord politique
ni candidats dans la même ville pourtant
ils partagent un point commun leur âge
avancé en vue d'un nouveau mandat de
maire élu à boisarcy depuis 19 ans et
arrivé sur la ville en 1969 Claude vuyet
80 printemps se sent prêt à repartir à
la conquête des bulletins de vote s'il
se dit tout à fait prêt à servir à
nouveau les arcisiens il lui a quand
même fallu consulter ses proches avant
de prendre sa décision je sais que je ne
suis plus un je suis pas un jeune homme
mais alors il se trouve que je suis en
en très bonne santé hein physiquement
intellectuellement les choses vont bien
donc je pense que je suis encore en
capacité d'assurer un mandat de maire
j'ai longuement réfléchi j'ai une femme
des enfants il sont tous arcisiens des
petits enfants donc ça fait l'objet de
d'un débat démocratique bien sûr en
vacances Henri paayux 74 ans est engagé
en politique depuis toujours déjà à 18
ans en 1958 il marchait au côté du
général de Gaulle mare à coignère depuis
1986 il se présente pour un 6e mandat
consécutif pour lui sa santé se porte
bien et il ne se présente donc pas pour
le mandat de trop je dois dire que je me
suis effec qui m'ont posé la question de
savoir si c'était pas comme certains le
disent à mandat de trop et bah comme
j'ai la santé pour l'assurer et bien je
suis intimement convaincu intimement
persuadé que j'ai encore de grands
services à rendre à la ville de Cadière
et au calierè autre exemple de ces
doyens au municipal ivelinoise
guimalandin 76 ans maire PS de trappe
depuis 2001 et encore dans la course
pour un nouveau mandat àe3 230 ans
cumulés ils entretiennent pourtant de
bons espoirs sur ce scrutin
une dernière information avant de
refermer ce journal nous avons appris
dans la journée que 144 iPad destinés
aux écoliers de saint-sir l'école ont
été volés dans le local informatique
d'une école primaire dans la nuit du 8
au 9 mars dernier 5 jeune hommes ont été
interpellé la valeur du butin s'élevé à
plus de 65000 € la commune s'est
constitué partie civile devant l'ampleur
du préjudice c'est la fin de cette
édition merci de l'avoir suivi à 18h30
vous retrouvez Cho avec Claire Cambier
qu à moi je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée sur
TVfil